did you celebrate last night after the
win I'm about body not about me well you
know it's on the bird a little bit make
sure everybody knew I computable be
forced to get some good recovery and get
everybody healthy so give money night
how did that feel though being on the
big stage finally with the Raiders
different man oh it was a little
overweight a man I fans with a lot of
problem animator of the minute and i
wanted to come out of other than his
work what is the scouting report on
Trevor siemian scotland for this be
stupendous no we got the last game see
buddy l quarterback girl so he's gonna
be some things because confidence I have
in a gang boots screams and they're
doing on the ball so we had to make a
monday mention of early in Game your
style especially it don't know why
should we buy into the Raiders convince
the you know the national audience here
because we're debating on how good the
Raiders are and are they are super bowl
contender about a man's game is a pretty
thing that all right really anticipate
that's good nothing phases are the
foundation unique we talked about
Oakland and a wheeled away and not
really going good bye Tommy project
almost under have you guys talked about
vegas at all probably discussion rocking
mama's boy okay you hear about mother
thank you focus on you know the kind of
like what I'm saying you know those
women all those different things going
on not a little focus alone in the
locker room mom which is a great thing
so everybody really just clicking the
word by women who's bigger you were
latavius Murray
I pay my beautiful breezy have you
tackled him like I did in the Pro Bowl
oh well maybe forgive the people who
practices back in the day when are you
headed big booming our aim low uh are
you allowed to hit car oh not at all
cannot get clothing from a fool what
what does coach Dale real do if you get
close if anybody gets close um oh yeah
nobody knows hey well congrats so far
it's been great and good luck against
the Texans that'll be next Monday night
so you got a few days off there and
congrats on the win no down that thanks
so much they're all right Khalil Mack
Raiders defensive linemen linebacker
wherever he wants to play the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience